to be here he worked hard yeah you're a
good guy dude don't be offended man i'm
not offended i love you bobby you're
always nice to me i want to thank kevin
for putting the studio together and uh
from afterbuzz
he did a great [ __ ] job he really did
he came in here and busted his balls
with papa
this is a nice place right here man it's
very nice yeah walking distance it's new
there's new spirits in here we got the
turntable
we got [ __ ] everything what's up with
you brother i'm good dude i just got
back from cleveland bro i was to
cleveland it was good the audience is
great but dude check it out celebrities
yeah dude great club so this manager
saturday no yeah saturday comes up
and goes here's a note and some dude
called in during the day and said here's
my review on bobby's set
right so he put he's disgusting i have
it on my twitter actually i'll read it
to you
oh sorry um yeah he he
first of all you don't give that to the
comic do you no a review you just let it
go right yeah i i was gonna kill you
owner of a manager he was a manager he
was new and then the and the top dude
the manager and the owner uh nick yelled
at him
you know nick's a good dude nick's a
good dude he's a good these are my
favorites he's like 75 years old this
guy's yeah they're wrestling strong yeah
you don't give a [ __ ] give a [ __ ] oh
here wanted to give feedback on bobby
lee's show found him to be very obscene
crude and tasteless
very nice those are good words
yeah but dude why would you call during
you know out of you to
put the time in to do that and someone
wrote it down at the club and then a
club and then if somebody wrote it down
to the club why would you write it down
and then why would you give it to me
like here here's your day's gonna be
[ __ ] listen to this near me it's like
it hurts your feelings
you still get your feelings hurt
dude like last week i was in um irvine
improv and 12 women got up and just
walked out five minutes of my set do you
know why why because these are 12 women
who met at a support group because their
kids all have down syndrome and my first
three minutes were about down syndrome
and so they got up and left did they
yell no but then they they they got
their money back from the club and then
the manager tells you after the show and
it makes you feel like [ __ ] it's like i
don't have anything against their kids
every time i'm with joey and someone
walks out you just laugh you love it i
laugh you do yeah you got to push some
of these buttons you have to you have to
yeah you have to you know to it's like
brad pitt said to make an omelette you
know break some eggs
so sometimes you got to hurt somebody's
[ __ ] feelings yeah but why would you
come out
right you just you you look at my photo
right i'm naked
in the photo you know what i mean and
they go bobby lee this weekend and then
12 older white women you know who have
downs babies you know i mean they all
come
and enjoy my they they know something's
gonna be sad like if you don't have 90
sets on youtube like you didn't take the
time to look at your youtube yeah like
if i was if i came to your show and i go
wow i'm a christian he swore a lot
well that's my bad
i mean i didn't know he was puerto rican
or whatever you know i mean or cuban
whatever you are yeah yeah whatever yeah
you know man you've called me chinese
before no i haven't
i always know your career oh you do yeah
oh what a good guy you're a good guy
you're a good dude i i've
listened you could you're gonna expect
people to get upset especially in
today's society and especially in the
society we live in
people gonna get accepts but what i
don't understand is it's like a movie
trailer before you go to the movie you
know there's some [ __ ] in the movie
or there's not you know it's pg or r
same thing with the club same thing with
youtube you could just go on youtube and
look at the comic oh i recognize them
from mad tv or from some [ __ ] movie
or whatever you know yeah but my thing
is is that i have a door deal
i don't give a [ __ ] if they left but
they get their money back right i'm
asian i want my money you want your
money yeah that was like that's like 22
dollars or whatever 25 bucks even if
they just thought three minutes [ __ ]
them [ __ ] your money yeah [ __ ] you i
want my [ __ ] 25 bucks
i'm from the oh
listen if they want to leave leave you
want your money back take the [ __ ]
money back you made a mistake
if you but most of these people in
today's society they go home write a
review on yelp
send you a [ __ ] email tell you i had
a guy that sent me a thing from vegas
because that was the [ __ ] dirtiest
show i've ever seen and he learned
something from cosby
oh is that what that's what he wrote to
me i'm like cosby rape [ __ ] women you
dirty dumb [ __ ] so you know that's the
you know
it just listen you're not gonna please
everybody
all the [ __ ] time somebody's gonna
get upset i feel bad when dead squad
guys come to my shows and bring their
wives
and they're like we love it you could
see the girls are like i don't even know
why i [ __ ] came here
this is crazy he's talking about eating
my ass and breaking into somebody's
house and that [ __ ] so i know most
women are sitting there going what the
[ __ ] but they love their men you know
and they tolerate that [ __ ] because it
makes them happy you know but the thing
is is that we don't think what we're
saying is wrong
like you know i do i have a bit about
like a tie hooker eating my butthole
right and then my girlfriend was like
yeah my mom was in the audience and i
just don't think you should have told
that joke i go what's wrong with it like
i don't know that it's wrong but i guess
well is it wrong it's it's not wrong
it's just that they don't
they're offended by it or that it makes
them weird you have to understand when a
midwestern white person or whatever
right they go to
they they have church on sundays right
they go to work from nine to five you
know i mean they have kids they don't
know anything about that so when i'm
bent over on a stool
and this asian lady's eating my butthole
right like to me that's every day you
know what i mean i think about that
every day yeah that's my life it's
lifestyle you know what i mean but to
them it's like oh
shocking you know i mean there's no man
in america that doesn't want his
butthole either
okay you said it
i love it i mean there's no man that
will say to you you know what i really
don't enjoy when a woman licks my ass so
that guy you just walk you like you do
you like eating butthole i like eating
it i like my [ __ ] eating but who am i
gonna talk to eat my ass you know what
i'm
this is probably just a big butthole
it's disgusting anybody's [ __ ] is
disgusting yeah that's my whole point
that's why it's delicious oh my god
everybody's like purple and like bulbous
is yours bulbous mine looks like a black
person's foot it's painfully [ __ ] it
looks like it's stepped on a firecracker
like a black dude stepped on a
firecracker mine's cute it's pink
mine's cute it's like pink and very
tight my poopoo looks like angel hair
pasta
you know it just comes out like a little
tiny noodles that's disgusting and i
know that's just i was thinking about it
no but you know think of
if a guy walks out of his shell there's
no man in america if a woman drops to
her knees and says i want to lick your
ass i don't believe in that
yeah i think there's a lot of guys who
would say no to that let me lick it well
you first of all no woman's going to
tell you she's going to lick your ass
she's just going to stick her tongue in
there and you're going to hit the
[ __ ] your eyeballs are gonna hit the
third eye is that really what happens
it's like the first time your girlfriend
doesn't eat your butthole no
look at me right now no why not at all
why not because i don't want her to
that's yeah that's on you oh but well i
don't that's on you and you gotta look
in the mirror
yourself man
okay listen i'm a big good i'm a big
dude there's no way like even after a
shower like today i took a shower and
then immediately had to take a [ __ ] so
i'm that's me it's never clean
but then how do you have a girl lick it
the thing is is that if they love you
they'll do it you know like i love my
girlfriend you know i've done it
you know and it's not
you know
there's like a
a taste you know
a residue
is it residue of [ __ ] but no but you
don't know what [ __ ]
yeah but [ __ ] doesn't taste like [ __ ] it
smells like [ __ ] when you eat [ __ ] it
doesn't taste like [ __ ] really what does
it taste like it tastes like food you
ate it it tastes like this no it died
the night before it's only brown now
with the taste of intestines
that same [ __ ]
that chicken corn and blue you eat at
night tastes the same way
in fact when you taste it you'll say to
yourself
[ __ ] it's a steak i eat it
it's only browning with the taste of it
intestine and grass yeah
i've never eaten [ __ ] but i smell my
finger after you scratch your [ __ ] so
when you looked at girl's butthole you
never tasted [ __ ] if i do what do i care
what are you part of the game that's
part it's a game it's vietnam i'm going
deep
what it tastes like a machete yeah once
you go down there what do you care about
right exactly i don't know [ __ ] and
sex are good enough for me man i don't i
don't know well you got to get freaky
from time to time that's freaking out
your ass up to the firecracker
let me ask you this do you okay do you
go down on your girl absolutely you do
absolutely and you don't travel south
nope
so you used that dmz line you just
stopped there
i crossed the table
of course you look at it because it's
there but it's like
what are you gonna do not look it's
there yeah like during doggy during
doggy you look at it but like i'm not
going to stick anything have you ever
seen your own [ __ ] i've never seen
mine when you go to the house do the
when you go and ask me colonoscopy they
send you pictures of the camera three
inches from your [ __ ] going in it
shows oh i never got that test you got
to do it all right you're not 50 yet oh
okay but you turned 50 to make it that
sag makes you this is the first time you
ever saw it that's yeah you know you had
a high def video i mean one that i was
like a little mirror back there to see
what was going on
yeah yeah but uh
yeah sag will make you get the camera up
the ass and also they'll send you an
envelope you gotta put a piece of [ __ ]
in there mail it in you gotta be kidding
me i swear to god a little bit fifty
wait wait give me a little envelope with
a little stick yeah you gotta [ __ ] and
take the stick and put it in the
envelope seal it and mail it to them and
what do they do with that test the
insides every like three years just to
make sure you [ __ ]
you don't swallow seriously [ __ ] like
that yeah i ain't 50 yet so maybe it'll
be i can't wait 50 50 yeah 49 they can't
wait kaiser called me when i was 49. sag
just gave me the envelope again to take
his [ __ ] in fact it was up here i left
it here because it was in my bag and
you still have the envelope it's around
here somewhere it was in the old office
before i moved it
jesus you're working on tv films what
are you doing well i'm doing that love
thing which is like judd's thing but i'm
only on three episodes and i did an
independent movie that uh universal just
bought i'm excited about but other than
that i'm just hitting the road hard you
know what i mean i'd like to talk about
you know i mean the john caparillo
situation
you know before we get on john capril i
want to tell you something as your
brother
you know you have gone from one step to
another in stand up like you stand up
now it's the best it's ever been you
dude you were killing me about two weeks
you're a [ __ ] beast bro i've been
watching you and i'm like this guy
changed dude completely that [ __ ] one
bit about the the irish movie yeah yeah
[ __ ] jungle [ __ ] with the filipinos i
still laugh at that i called my filipino
friends and told them they're like [ __ ]
him
yeah you bring that up every few months
like i guess you're like bobby lee calls
asian jungle i don't love it jungle
asians not jungle [ __ ] bro jungle asians
yeah jungle asians because my
girlfriend's a jungle asian that's why
yeah that's why i said i think i can say
that filipino yeah but if once we break
up then i can't say it no more i can't
say it yeah yeah yeah but it's funny now
you have to what's the girl wang up at
the store
who's wrong the dirty girl from chelsea
baby ali wong she's the best and she was
saying the other day you know i'm
chinese and something and my husband's
japanese and something and we sit home
and talk about filipinos or whatever
i love her i love her that joke about
that she had to have a kid because the
[ __ ] wasn't getting moist anymore yeah
oh my god i'm sitting the back going
what the [ __ ]
you know what's great about the store
now though is that since you and joe
have come back no everybody it's just
just no [ __ ] listen to what the [ __ ]
i'm saying
will you listen to what the [ __ ] i'm
saying yeah i'm giving you a compliment
right
but you have to understand it came you
came with the new changes right because
i've been there
since the dark ages i never left right
so i've seen it you know grow i've seen
it destroyed and it's better
now than it's ever been when was the
first time you stepped foot i would i
went to the first time a hollywood about
1996. wow yeah and i was young i was a
kid i was scared and i did a belly room
show
and i i got a couple of laughs and i
called my mom like i'm gonna make it you
know i remember dante being there you
know dante the comic for you yeah yeah
and he goes you did a good job [ __ ]
dante and i'm never gonna talk to that
guy again okay he [ __ ] me i'm gonna
talk about that later okay but aside
from that um yeah so i was 96 and then i
moved up here
in 98 and i got a doorman job
and it was rough bro
two years of just struggling
it was like i remember one time i was
sleeping out of my truck because i was
like between places to live and jimmy
schubert
during the day knocked down my window i
was sleeping in my truck
and he got hey kid uh you hungry
i go yeah i'm gonna buy a sandwich
jimmy schubert walked me down the street
to um greenblatt's and he bought me a
sandwich and i'll never [ __ ] forget
it
you know it's that kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
that i never forget man you know dice
did that too a couple of times and
that's why i mean people don't like
mencia
and i understand why but he was very
good to you but he follows you very much
he bought me a [ __ ] car
like i didn't do anything he was i was
his opener
and he goes hey dude he's a car you know
i mean it wasn't new it was his sister's
his girlfriend's sister's car
but still it's like they didn't have to
do that you know i mean so it's like
i've had
that relationship with carlos you know i
mean but the whole time when i was
opening for him yes you saw that he
lifted bits you know what i mean but i
would defend him because of the fact
that he did so much for me i was so poor
and the agent that i have now is because
of carlos you know i'm still with matt
you know and it's like
you know i am loyal you know and when
that [ __ ] went down
i was divided because i love joe rogan
like joe rogana are a very good friend i
love him my friends i've been to his
house you know you know i love the guy
he's a great guy but i was caught in the
[ __ ] middle of this [ __ ] war
it was the worst
two years when of my life seriously
because when that video came out that
joe you know joe exposed carlos with the
bill cosby thing
you remember yeah you looked very
uncomfortable yeah i was in that video
so you know what he did carlos made me
do a rebuttal video
so i was because i remember mad tv was
right next to mind of mencia it was
during the last couple of years of mad
and he caught me on set
right he him
his brother his brother and albert they
sat me down they go you're gonna do this
rebuttal video that he doesn't steal
and then when that went out oh my god i
had death threats for a year
from comics i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
you're never gonna work again i mean i
would it was crazy dude
so it was a really [ __ ] difficult
time dude i'll tell you i knew i met
carlos
in the summer of 94 on the hbo latino
local slam tour yeah
okay i had [ __ ] eight minutes of
material
and i got picked to open from to do five
minutes i'll never forget that night
because i had the kid who gave me a
drive a ride
brought his girl he was from brooklyn
like you know the movies you see from
brooklyn
like he was from brooklyn and the girl
he brought from brooklyn was from
brooklyn and he would tell her shut the
[ __ ] up and sing
just in the in the middle of nothing in
the middle of the night we were driving
he would go coco this is janice
and we got in the car and he's like
where are we going denver to this place
another way she would say i love the
mountain shut the [ __ ] up and sing
i told you to sing and she would sing
she would sing like a disco song there
you were and he would tell her shut up
[ __ ] keep talking wow then she would
sing for two then she would say
something again and he'd go what'd i
just tell you sing a [ __ ] song she
wants to be a singer coco and she would
sing in the car on the way there it was
[ __ ] horrible the girl was horrible
he kept telling don't worry i'm gonna
make calls for you i'm gonna make you a
star just keep [ __ ] singing what were
you doing as she was singing just
sitting in the back dying in the back
just dying
but i took carlos's number
and i called him after that he was very
good to me when i got to the store
carlos was one of the ones that made a
call for me to be a regular at the store
so i too was in the middle of that you
know uh
i knew carlos for the longest time yeah
uh
well i mean it can't what are you doing
that was his number then oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah how long why i've known
carlos i still remember his name
i used to call him up and ask him for
help i knew carlos and i was in the same
[ __ ] position in the way i felt bad i
felt remember we were in the latino
laugh festival uni in san antonio we had
no money no money you and i had no money
his manager took us out yes where is he
where are you ruthie patterson yeah he's
still around yeah yeah his kids are
grown and stuff i think he works for
another big bigger management firm i
don't know how well he's doing but
yeah were they bought us meals because
we couldn't eat couldn't he do you
believe that [ __ ] it's i mean
it's uh
just because someone steals jokes and
because they're a bad they do bad things
professionally doesn't mean they're a
bad person
i mean i mean
but in comedy though you know i mean i
can understand why people i mean that's
always why it always shocks me when
people who do stuff like that are also
[ __ ]
like yeah if you're gonna if you're
gonna do shitty things
be a nice person at least try to be a
nice person
on other aspects of your life and it's
funny because i was thinking about this
today
because all the amy schumer stuff
another one came another allegation came
out today and i was sitting there
thinking tomorrow alligator
somebody she stole another sketch for
his show oh yeah
i'm sitting there going you know i still
remember when somebody came to me
and said to me about carlos
and
they said a couple of things they wanted
to do to him and i said listen
you're not going to accomplish nothing
with smacking this kid i'll never forget
this i said what you need to do is let
him do what he's doing
and eventually he'll kill himself
you know i didn't mean it in a bad way
because i'm a thief i'm a real thief i
know it is to put a gun to somebody i
noticed a break in somebody's window but
i would never rob somebody's joke i knew
the price i paid when i was thiefing i
know the prices i paid i could name 20
of them the price i paid so you always
pay for your [ __ ] cents
you know when i first started the
business the biggest joe thief on the
world was robin williams everybody told
you when i started 91 that was the
biggest thing people would tell you he's
a [ __ ] joke thief he paid people off
like stephen pearl he stole from brian
bradley yeah you know so you have to
think to yourself didn't this guy kill
himself
you know yeah
it's something that's really weird i'm
going to ask bobby lee a question this
is going to be the weirdest question
bobby lee of tonight god forbid
and this is a big god forbid you're on
your way to heaven
what and you made your decision you made
the decision i'm just saying like if i
if i killed you no no if you've never
killed yourself let's pretend if i die
and i think of this whole comedy game on
the way up and what i really got from
kylie game it wasn't the audiences it
wasn't the money it wasn't the ability
to make people laugh to me is what you
said when somebody did give you a call
when my car broke down in nebraska and
some girl picked me up and gave me a
ride to the gas station and stopped and
bought me food when
bobby lee gave me huh i went up to bobby
when i go bobby
i'm broke and he gave me how long i was
out of his pocket never asked me for it
joe rogan who hated cocaine hated
cocaine a couple nights i got to the
point where i needed money i go joe i
need money he'd go
and he'd give it to me ralphie may you
know the people who take care of you
without you even asking he gave you a
call there's so many great lessons i've
learned from comedy
so many great [ __ ] lessons that you
sit there and go
holy [ __ ] you know holy [ __ ] and here i
thought
it was going to be this and look how
nice this was you know you don't get
there
by yourself
it's impossible never never i mean if
you look back of like who
got you you know i mean audition for a
club or who put in a good word for you i
mean all the little tiny [ __ ] things
right you can't just do it by yourself
you need people
you need people that are ahead of you
that have some sort of power
and and that's why i do it now it's like
if you want a commercial agent i know
the dude my dude you know from aqua he's
a korean dude korean that's
yeah so it's like i help you know i do
it you know not because i'm a good
person it's because that's the way
the thing is supposed to [ __ ] work
you know i mean you got to help people
without any young comics we have nothing
we have nothing we have nothing i tell
all the time those young comics are like
keep me in chicken college when i'm 70.
they're all gonna when they're all stars
they're gonna go i know who can play my
grandpa this kid jack knight who i had
me ope i had him open a year ago on in
la brea brea improv
comedy central came out to see me right
they didn't like my hat but they liked
him he was a kid black kid right he they
gave him like three shows you know like
you know adam devine's beach party
whatever that was and now chappelle's
using them as an opener and jack is like
is that all right with me i'm like dude
i want you to [ __ ] do it
when i saw you a year ago
right he only had 15 minutes right he's
21 years old he's a cute black very good
writer right i'm like i know it's going
to happen for you
yes so go
fly
you know without them we got nothing
and that's why
when john went crazy you know i mean
caparillo
eight years ago or whatever you know i
mean it just baffles me
you know it was very sad because i saw
him when he came into the store and we
were friends i remember he was a doorman
and one night he kept saying to me i
don't get spots and i go you know why
you don't get sponsors you don't pay
duncan
he goes what are you talking about you
gotta pay duncan fifteen dollars a spot
he goes but that's what they pay me i
don't give a [ __ ] you didn't know that
every week on friday you got to give
duncan 75 bucks and he'll give you five
spots i've been doing it for years why
do you think i got so many spots
and duncan's walking towards me i go don
come here this [ __ ] kid don't know
yeah they supposed to pay you 15 a spot
he's like yeah i go every friday you got
to pay a thing
and you got to give it to me and i'll
give it to duncan okay
and he was go for it and finally i gave
him a hug and i go cap this and we
laughed and it was hilarious yeah and
then one day he comes up to me and he
pulls rank on me and and then yeah you
know that's all that happened i mean
they already know the listeners now tell
me your version i'm just gonna tell you
what happened okay all right so
john cabarillo's from
ohio he came off the bus you know
great family comes from a great family
but he's a a white kid you know kind of
like on the other side of white which
means that he's low economic you know
and but he's a smart kid
super driven
and he started dating sheamatash who i
lived with remember shayma the turkish
girl she's not carrot tops opener
she i talked to her three weeks ago yeah
she was very very funny
so she was dating um
john and john here's what happens
when you
when you're nothing
and then all of a sudden one day they
say you're something
sometimes
you take that power right and it [ __ ]
up your brain
so there was a couple of years there
where he thought that he was the [ __ ]
because he was hot he was one of the
best panelists on
chelsea lately and he was his specials
were good and um it got to his head i
mean one night he told me that
hey man i don't want to do the same show
with you at the comedy store so
tommy tommy's gonna have to figure it
out i go yeah there's only one show dude
so if i'm not doing the same show with
you i'm out
he's like well you're not a real comic
anyway that's what he told me
okay
so in my head i wanted to [ __ ] take a
knife and puncture his throat you know
what i mean just you know mate right his
throat but i'm not murderer i'm gonna do
that right so i let it seep
and then tommy separated us on the
lineup for a couple years
and then several years later he toned
down you know but that was right round
you mean when you had a problem with him
so it's just that he's just one of those
kids that
got something and then it got to his
head and he went [ __ ] crazy
well you know the longest yard got to my
head
the longer shot got to my head okay the
movie yeah when you're on it when you're
there for six weeks and often they put
you on for 17 weeks and you're rubbing
shoulders adam sound and every [ __ ]
a.d and every producer is telling you
when this movie comes out you're gonna
[ __ ] hit it [ __ ] with your head it
[ __ ] in my head a lot a lot of [ __ ]
in my head yeah not once i go to the
store and bump not once did i go to the
store and tell the talent coordinator i
didn't want somebody on the lineup
because they were funny in me or they
weren't funny in me that didn't make me
do all that craziness he had this other
thing going with tommy
and i get it and i get all the other
stuff but the creepy things he did was
get in front of somebody's talent
that was the creepy thing he did he did
it to you he did it to dalia he did it
to a couple other guys and i don't want
to beat this horse to death because it's
gone he's done he's you know he's not
going to [ __ ] fight with me yeah he's
not going to come back at me i'm not
going to do nothing to him i just want
to let him know how i felt yeah that i
didn't forget about this i don't forget
about anything whether you do something
bad to me or do you do something good to
me about anything i don't want to beat
him up i don't want to fist fight him he
attacked me and i just told him he was
and you know what's funny
there are people at the store that are
actors that become comics there are
those people you my friend are not one
of them you are not one of them you were
a comedian first you banged it out with
us yeah yeah yeah yeah i remember your
little brother coming to the show yeah
you know you banged it out first you
gained the acceptance of your father
this was big for you this was big for
you you're not some white dude from
orange county you gotta go home and tell
your dad i want to be a [ __ ]
community he looked at you and going
what are you [ __ ] [ __ ] get to
some [ __ ] go make some kimchi or
whatever the [ __ ] you're going to do but
you remember
yeah i mean this was big for you this
was big for a lot you know
he just did some things that yeah
whatever you know you're in a bad state
of mind do i forgive them i'm done i
don't really give a [ __ ] like i told you
man those people ice themselves when you
do that type of [ __ ] if you don't pay
the piper
it starts [ __ ] with your head later
on you know i know in life i've paid the
[ __ ] pipe i paid for my sins heavily
man when i used to be a thief my life
yeah i was snorting coke and getting my
dick sucked but let's look at what
really was going on inside i was living
on people's couches i had no life i was
broken inside so bro you pay for all
that so bad when i was using i gave you
so many drugs i don't give a [ __ ] you
remember that though [ __ ] yeah i used to
give you just piles of pills and stuff
and i just feel so bad i'm 14 years
sober now but back in the day dude i
remember seeing diaz and i had to get
out my briefcase
and pull it out you know what i mean i
was a medicine man back then man
remember that you used to sleep in your
bathtub and [ __ ] i used to sleep in the
bathtub because of the sleep apnea
and leave the hot water on all night and
just sleep in the tub and let the water
hit me so i can breathe and you would be
able to sleep with the water oh i love
sleeping with water on what if i get a
pillow and put a garbage bag on it is
this a relapse because i've been 14
years old advice i'm fine with it but
this isn't open no no don't don't don't
look at it
no no no no it's fine it's already
happened it's kind of anticipated no
it's pie it's fine you know i mean i'm
not buzzed i'm fine
but can you get high like that though uh
maybe with his stuff but not i don't i
think he'll be fine all right but like
how
like is it hard because you could both
have had pretty
great careers like
i know you're not done but you've had
good things happen to you is it hard not
to
start being like oh i'm going to bump
all these people at the store i'm going
to do all that like it must
somebody why would i want to do that why
would i call in on a monday they gave me
15 [ __ ] minutes that's enough time
sometimes i'll do 20 you know and then
i'm out why would i they'll give me my
spot i called in today they're gonna
give me a spot pretty much every night
if there's one night they might not but
that's fine and i'll just do it and
that's it
why would i go mysteriously
unannounced and then go up to a kid
you know i mean who's struggling and go
by the way
me and joey are gonna bump you and
you're not gonna go on for another hour
why would i do that
i think it's the same you could say the
same thing like why do these bankers
defraud people like it's
you could make the argument that it's
just never enough for some people
there's never enough money there's never
enough stage time yeah i but also i
think the communist stores run in a way
that you can't do that anymore really i
mean the guy i'll tell you who can bump
and it's only a handful louis c.k
chris rock
dave chappelle
bill burr
maybe sarah silverman because she'll
just she's you know who she is and
she'll only do 10 minutes anyway you
know i mean but that's pretty much it
and i have no problem with that yeah
neither i have no problem logan rogan
can do it i have no problem with that
and he won't know he won't do it but he
could
but if bill bill has come up to me bro
and chappelle or whatever and they said
hey can i go before you yes yes
absolutely
i don't care you know because it's not
like what they used to do in the 90s
when eddie griffin used to do three
hours
do you remember that [ __ ] oh my god
three hours andrew dice would do three
hours
so that would mean that if you had a 9
45 spot you're not getting up
you would literally you would literally
see dice's car
pull up and you would just leave
or yeah but not just leave you would
scream
right and throw something a [ __ ] you
know what i mean and then you would get
in the car and then leave because you
had no spot no money and you wanted that
15 bucks that needed 50 dollars 15 you
counted on that 16. they wouldn't give
it to you if you got bumped no no i
wanted you to stay and wait yeah so
unless you stayed and wait two and a
half i mean eddie griffin would go on a
tent and stay on till [ __ ] ten to two
and then what i left you a little
something yeah what would he say for
three hours he would talk about for an
hour how he was jesus one night
for two hours he was trying to convince
the room that he was literally jesus
christ
you know and it wasn't jokes i'm jesus
and that's it
i'll tell you why you know what i mean
it's like what
and that would and they would let that
you know i mean happen and that's why
industry never came that's why the real
credible comics never wanted to play
there but now everyone plays there
because it's run
fairly
and it's a it's the best room in l.a
it's right by far by far by far
like when flappers check this out
when did flappers come out five years
five years okay so this is what happens
i get the call from the lady what's her
lady's name barbara barbara right she
calls me goes hi left a message hi i'm
barbara i'm opening up a comedy club
called flappers and um i remember you
from back in the day you know i mean
from my visits at the comedy store
and i would like you to perform at my
room i called her immediately and i said
i'd love to do it so you have weekends
she goes well you're not a weekend guy
i go excuse me
yeah i'm having jimmy dore
and you know these names on it and avi
lieberman you know they're the the
headliners and they're doing the
weekends you're more of a tuesday
call-in you know i mean and i'm like
[ __ ] i'm with caa
[ __ ]
you know what i mean i got i've done
movies and tv shows [ __ ]
i didn't say that
i didn't say that i go okay
that's what i said okay and then i hung
out right but it's like i will never
play that room
and then a year later she left another
message i'm so sorry you can do a
weekend how do i you know what i mean
but at that point done
[ __ ] done i will i have stepped in
that room maybe twice in my life just
because my girlfriend was performing the
open mic there because she wanted to try
stand up and i had another friend to
open michael whatever i stopped i was
there last tuesday at open mic no and uh
they do a tuesday yeah yeah dang and i
was there on tuesday have you ever done
a weekend now
one time i did the friday night well
there you go but i never did it again
nice club but i just i need to do it
yeah well it's not good right it's a
good club and they get good people and
it's burbank
uh i just thought that the whole thing
wasn't worth the aggravation like i got
[ __ ] you know debt squad people don't
buy tickets till friday they're stoners
and she kept calling me wednesday and
two's like you're not selling tickets
you got to give away tickets and i'm
like i ain't giving away dick cancel me
and then friday she came in and
apologized she goes hey man when i got
here there was a bunch of stoners out
there
and she's a nice lady it's a great club
it's just not what we're used to and
there's a lot of clubs that we're not
meant for bobby lee and we go there one
time and you know when you walk in
you're like
oh
this is not me i i've literally gone up
to club owners and said
it's a nice club
don't ever ask me back
no you have i have
this is the worst weekend of my life
no you i have i don't give off because i
don't
even want them to call my agent to even
see
one of the guys at kansas city right he
was a christian the wig or the club
improv improv oh right he's a christian
and when i told him that he goes
can you get on your knees and pray with
me
i go what
so we get on the knees because
it wasn't a joke because dear lord
please
open bobby's heart you know to this club
you know what i mean and i'm like i got
up i got back on my two feet and i i i i
was holding my hair was sweaty you know
what i mean
like it was like vibrating and it was
sweaty and i got up and i got dude this
is the [ __ ] reason
this is the reason i don't want to come
back here was it just too clean
it's just the i i one show a lady stood
up and i didn't even know what this word
meant i had to google it
she goes heathen
never heard it before in my life
in the middle of kansas city they just
called you a heathen yeah
i didn't know what the [ __ ] i meant i
i'm [ __ ] i don't know what i meant
and then i googled it i go that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i ain't no [ __ ] heathen
you know and as soon as that happened i
gotta never come to the [ __ ] place
again was the food good was the classic
the hotel photos yeah and you just
didn't like the club you know dude it's
like if it's a lot of white people
like 99.9 white i generally
can't play it do you know why why
because of a cultural connection
if i play seattle 30 of my room are
mixed either asian black latino right
and if i talk about my parents on my
upbringing and if it's all white people
they just don't get it i mean the jokes
because it's constructed where i have a
punchline right they do giggle at it
right but it's not that like
where like i really
know what you're talking about
and i just don't want to
do i don't want to convince people you
know i mean of who i am
you know i mean it's like i just played
cleveland and i i'll play i only play
that room because of nick the owner of
hilarity he's one of the best people
i've ever met best the best and the
audience is they i sold out you know i
mean and audiences are great you know i
mean but it's hard
it's hard
like every show i have to walk out and
they go you kill i go i don't know i you
know i had a hard time there too yeah in
the middle you i lost them a little bit
yeah yeah yeah yeah when i was talking
about my purple nut sack you know i mean
how ethnic guys have purple nut sacks
and stuff and they're like ours is pink
you know what i mean yeah but mine's
just purple i don't believe you you know
it's that kind of thing where if there's
ethnic people there go yeah dog my
mind's purple too or whatever you know
what i mean where else have you played
the
play
okay so they're pittsburgh oh my god
steve byrne told me to play cuz he's
from there right yeah you're from there
you're gonna and you're also half white
right i'm full asian
i went there i mean you're talking about
60 people on a friday for a show
yeah i mean it's like
i'm swinging 500 seats sold out at
irvine improv right
schomburg improv sell out every show
how's charlotte
amazing you like shawn yeah because it's
close enough to chicago and there's just
you know the cultural element is there
canada i [ __ ] love
canada's the [ __ ] best everywhere in
canada but there's some place oh you
know what the worst one was
denver
improv
have you played there yes oh my god
that was the worst you know what
happened to me though why didn't you
like the denver improv i'll tell you one
night okay i do a thursday show friday
show in front of like 40 people a show
i'm not [ __ ] kidding you
saturday
first show i walk in the club
the doorman put me in a headlock
he put me in a black guy he put me in a
headlock he goes yo dawg where's your
ticket i swear to [ __ ] god
i'm on your third night there yeah it's
my third night i go
i'm the headliner
and he let me go is that my bad
[ __ ] you're supposed to [ __ ] know
that already
you know it's not like we're you know
it's not like a movie complex what does
it make me a poster at the front door
well it's not like there's 12 comics in
12 different rooms you know what i mean
it's one room
one guy playing the whole weekend
right
know who that guy is
the same happened to me in seattle
and i got him fired
in seattle i did two shows i walked in
club american indian long-haired parades
hey bo you you you sold out i go i'm the
headliner and when i got off the stage
he was fired
i didn't say the firearm they just did
it because it's embarrassing
but then i got him his job back the next
day i felt bad because he had kids and
stuff and he's american indian you know
what i mean yeah but how can you not
know how you should [ __ ] know who
your [ __ ] headliner is so it's denver
out i went to comedy works
you know that's the [ __ ]
yeah i made pittsburgh out
never again
i i'll tell people i love you people in
pittsburgh
if you're listening right now but i
can't play that room again
it's a disaster
you know here's another one [ __ ] i
can't play [ __ ]
dallas what
what addison improv why not
i just it's it's easy
it's chaos
there's a beer thrown on the stage you
know what i mean a girl has her titty
out in the front row that's a crazy room
yeah and it used to be crazy ten years
ago yeah like it's like crazy
put your titty
that's a away neighborhood addison yeah
it's next to a karaoke bar oh my god
yeah it's like you know the dueling
piano the dueling piano yeah dueling
piano so it gets all those knuckleheads
in because if you go to a dueling piano
you decide to get hit in the head with
the [ __ ] people it's in the same room
right next door so you hear the piano
and [ __ ] yeah
all right it's a great i've always had
fun at the dallas improv it's a good
room i just didn't never made any
[ __ ] money and i'm done with it i
tried it 10 [ __ ] times
and i'm done with it houston i kill it
it's so weird like some places you do
really
oh my god i can't even [ __ ] believe
you just brought that up dude how's
austin i'm going to tell you something
that happened to me in austin
and i can't even believe you just said
that because and it's the mo it's an
atrocity right and i'm gonna sue i might
sue
i was playing austin a year ago okay on
the books
matt blake calls me he goes you're out
of your
week a weekend right you're out of
boston
i go why
because rich miller called me and said
that the year before
you were in a limo
with the limo driver you pulled your
dick out and you told the limo driver to
suck your dick
that's what he said did you no what what
the [ __ ]
no i didn't do that right i go excuse me
matt first of all when have i ever been
in a [ __ ] limo
and number two nick youssef my opener
was with me every second of every day i
never [ __ ] did that why would i do
that i'm sober right i go give me rich
miller's number rich miller is dennis
miller's brother
they don't know that people are
listening right so rich miller is dennis
miller's brother and he books comedy
rooms right and he lives in minnesota
i don't know the [ __ ] guy right i
call rich miller
he answers i go dude
i never pulled my dick out
and told some white limiter to suck my
dick i'm not gay and also i'm sober like
i'm in the aaa i have a sponsor you know
me i pray i meditate why the [ __ ] would
i do that he goes i don't know anything
about that
i double booked you
right i double booked you and it's the
other guy's a friend of mine he has no
money but i'll get you back on the books
that's what the [ __ ] guy tells me
right
i hang up the phone i call matt i go
that's what rich said
he didn't even mention the dick sucking
thing right so the mat called it rich
again
matt calls me back yeah
you did it
the dick sucking
so the rich miller can't say it to my
face
he lies to me on my face right and then
tells my agent that i did it
i never did it and then i had my manager
and my lawyer call the club itself to
bypass rich and they won't answer our
phone calls i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened there i love that [ __ ] room
that's a great room i know it is
i know it's a great room but i never why
would i why would i tell a stranger
a guy to suck my dick
i know
i just okay listen listen to me right
now okay okay
ask me if i've ever sucked a dick before
have you sucked a dick yes whoa
i have when in high school
why
because i was drunk i'm not gonna tell
you who it was with a bunny
he pulled his dick out
and i was now we're not high school i
was like maybe eighth to ninth grade
okay
eight to ninth grade okay okay did he
finish no no i just tasted a couple
times i didn't like it was salty right
so check it out
so i sucked it all right
i'm willing to admit
every [ __ ] awful
dirty thing i've ever [ __ ] done i'm
not
i'm not a [ __ ] angel i've made
mistakes i've been in and out of
sobriety i've relapsed before
i know my failures and i know exactly
what i've done in my [ __ ] life all
right
if you've asked you know when they say
were you molested by a guy with down
syndrome yes
he stuck his little sweaty fingers in my
butthole when i was nine
and he gave me candy and i went back
every [ __ ] day for three summers in a
row to get that candy
and i let him stick his [ __ ] sweaty
fingers in my butthole and i jerk them
off i don't give a [ __ ] i want the
[ __ ] dip candy you know you had the
dip you know with the stick right right
so i went back
eating me every day for three summers
road to get my
candy what was it going on during the
school year what you what why why do you
only go to the customers because he was
the guy that mowed the lawn at the
[ __ ] skating rink during the summer
and then during the winter it was so he
never lived there but in the summer he
was like the groundsman right so it was
only in the summer and he lived in the
shack there right and he had this candy
on the rafters i'm just telling you this
right now because of the fact that it's
a dark thing
but it's like i'm i'll admit to it all
right you know i've i've told my parents
every dirty thing i've ever [ __ ] done
and i've done many all right and i've
apologized for bad things
but i never pulled my dick out to a limo
driver until it's like my dick that
never [ __ ] happened
and then i'm banned from a room and then
i wanted to sue and then my agent's like
dad i do business with them with my
other clients you know he was with ca so
i like can you not i mean i'll i'll back
you up so i let it go i'm telling you
right now rich miller i never [ __ ]
did that [ __ ] and you should be [ __ ]
shamed of yourself
okay
people hey listen in 98 i went to
florida
97 summer in 97 i went to west palm
beach when it was d.o club
i got there wednesday i headlined
wednesday
headline thursday and friday saturday
the black chick from night court was
headlining
marshall warfield marshall warfield just
before she died i love you
and this before she died and
that saturday she died i think she died
i don't know
and uh that saturday
that friday i i mean i had people in
miami and i bought blow
in miami that friday and then that
thursday i got high but that saturday i
was talking to the waitress
and the waitress comes over to me like
hey man can you get some blow and she
goes yeah so i go how much 90 whatever i
give him the money
20 minutes later the club manager comes
in he goes hey man
don't ever ask my waitress for a blog at
me she ain't giving it to me already
yeah he goes next time come to me
that's not where i thought you were
going with it yeah i go i didn't know
nobody [ __ ] sent me the memo you know
next time i'll go to you yeah okay
that sunday night where the club owner
was i don't need to mention his name
i do the early show at seven [ __ ]
show finishes at 8 30. do you know what
11 o'clock i still wasn't paid
because he was doing blow in the green
room with whoever the [ __ ] some other
one of the other headliners
and i could even smell the free basin
okay
i bought the grandma coke
i got high i didn't get high at the club
i didn't hit on any of the waitress i
got hired my cousins
friday whatever saturday i got high in
the hotel you could the condo was so bad
the condo didn't even have a [ __ ]
a shower curtain i mean i had to stay
with my cousin
the point of the story is i came home
and three months later some headliner
comes up to me goes hey man what'd you
do in west palm beach that owner will
hate you
he says you were doing [ __ ] blow
okay the owner was doing blow on
saturday and sunday [ __ ] night in the
green room with the other comic that was
at the uh yeah because they had davey
and they had whatever doesn't really
matter who the [ __ ] it was but it's
amazing how people will say [ __ ] it
depends how we take it i was very
insulted and i saw him after that i
never talked to him again ever since
then things have changed and now when i
see him he's my best friend and he wants
to talk and you're doing great
but it's [ __ ] crazy yeah i was at the
store one night in the very beginning
97 and i went to the door guy and i
asked him for blow and i gave him a
hundred bucks and he gave me six
twenties for a hundred
so i had six twenties i think i had an
audition the next morning i was gonna do
two of them
i had four of them that i would have
given away you know what i'm saying yeah
i do a couple bumps a comic comes in
there well known come he comes in i just
met him and he goes hey man
i'm [ __ ] exhausted i go you want a
blast he goes yeah
i give him two blasts and i go hey take
one of the packages do you know a month
later he went to a pitch meeting and my
name came up and the guy called me a
coke fiend
no
after i gave him
a famous guy yeah pretty much you're not
gonna name him no
are you friends with this famous he
apologized instead of hitting him up he
did yeah he hit him i would have [ __ ]
killed him years later i told him what
else he asked me what happened when it
comes to industry dude oh my god
somebody [ __ ] you with industry oh yeah
tears in his eyes he did that yo he had
oh my god i was gonna kill him for you
just because i was really mad when i was
telling him like i it hurt my feelings
i said that's what i get for dealing
with [ __ ] gentiles and i'll never do
it again
and i learn but it's really weird
because
years later i've heard stories where
people with coke fiends were people and
when they hit they stopped talking to
those people
like i know a lot of people that have
done coke with certain celebrities
that's why i always took never to do
coke with people because they'd stop
talking to you so that's why that's what
i learned real quick in 98
that never do blow with people like i
sold blow to somebody one day like a
well-known agent called me one day was
at the store and became friends and he
called me one day out of the blue and he
goes hey man can you get me blow and i
said yeah so go meet me at el compadre
i'm gonna blow in like an hour later he
called me back
that it wasn't what he wanted he want
and i'm like hey and then he never
talked to me again
like you know what i'm saying so it was
weird and i heard like there was this
guy i knew this guy at karate on sunset
boulevard he was a big guy and i used to
talk to him after karate and [ __ ] and
one day he goes can i buy you a beer we
went over
and i became friends with the guy and he
showed me this this is a great story we
walked back after about three months one
night he goes let's go back to my house
and smoke a joint went back to his house
he goes i want to show you something
and he started showing me [ __ ]
pictures of him
in 1995
and 96
with a bunch of guys with blow
everywhere and the beach behind them he
took pictures of blows like he just
showed pictures of people partying you
know when you do a blow and there's
women and there's mirrors and there's
lines on it and one and one of the guys
that was in every picture was james
gandolfini god bless his soul
wow he told me a very interesting story
he goes
i was with that guy for two years every
weekend he was part of a clique that
came down to party on the beach they all
lived in hollywood
and they would come down the party on
the beach
and they would get pills and drugs and
whatever and gandafini was one of those
guys he goes i became good friends with
him because i remember driving him to
the set of the movie with the boat
what's the movie with denzel and gene
hackman on the boat that movie they made
with uh the mutiny and [ __ ] like that
that was james gallafini's big like
james started working he started booking
like get shorty when travolta beats him
up he's in a bunch so he goes i still
remember him driving him to that set wow
you know like i was talking and him
being hungry
crimson tide that's being what year was
that 95 85. eight i'm sorry
i remember him you know driving him and
having a conversation with him and this
guy was a big italian guy
and he goes that he remembers one
weekend talking to him and him going i'm
going to new york to shoot a pilot
for some mafia show it's not going to
get picked up
you know it's not going to get picked up
yeah you know because i'm going to miss
you guys and [ __ ]
but they got to go to new york well the
show got picked up yeah and he goes one
day i caught gang the feeny because i
got his number from one of my friends
and i said hey jimmy it's [ __ ]
whatever
this guy since then died
and he goes uh jimmy it's whatever
listen man the sopranos are looking for
this role can you help me out he goes
bro i love you to all my heart
because that was a long time ago man i
really can't help you good luck and he
hung up on and he goes galloping he
wasn't a bad guy
but he just didn't want me on the set
with bad [ __ ] habits the same bad
habits he had yeah because i figured
that out a year late i bumped into him
he didn't want him on the set jimmy told
him to his face he goes broke i had
enough problems on my own
you know i'm having a hard time in new
york on my own every place i walk into
somebody wants to get me a coke rock now
i need you to [ __ ] come up to me and
[ __ ] hang out with me so plus i mean
how often do you guys get hit up by
friends who
you can't help everybody out but at
least yeah the oh so also but also a set
though it's like it's a it's a workplace
right and it's like
you don't need it's also stressful he's
the star of the show correct and he's
got lines to memorize the last thing you
need is an element that's like a little
weird it's like
in the eight years i was on mad tv no
one came i had my dad come one time you
know i mean like i just it's my job you
know what i mean it's like people were
hey can i get tickets
no
what do you want to come for i had to
work
you know
oh [ __ ]
you know it's really interesting
statement you made before
because you can't get to this place by
yourself like i remember having no
credits and going into like uh
you're gonna love this having basketball
and having a pilot having a commercial
but i needed that tv show i just [ __ ]
needed that tv show
and i got a call one day hey man
mad tv is doing a sketch about the
sopranos
go in there just go down there
and i made some calls and i found out
the office where it was
and i [ __ ] went down there because
they submitted me too late so they go
just go down there and crash the
audition and when i get there they stop
seeing people there was nobody there but
who walked out of the [ __ ] office
that was writing the black kid aries
harry spears with the impersonations you
know how many times harry spears talked
to me before that
zero he would see me at the store and go
what's up brother you wonder how many
times he said hi to me at eight years of
on the show with them zero okay but
here's the thing he said hello to me
zero times at the store i would do
freaky monday with him and the other guy
the black shell but guess what when he
walked out of that door he made
uncontact with me
and he walked over and he goes you here
for the soprano bit
and i go yeah he goes hold on one minute
and he knocked on the door
he went in i could tell everybody the
truth you know yeah yeah he walked in
and he came on he came out with some
lady and he introduced me to the main
lady
and he goes nicole garcia yeah he goes
my [ __ ] from the store you know
give me some love and [ __ ] and i went in
there and booked it wow you know
grudge match i got a call from the
director you know think of all the
things that we've booked just because
we've known somebody yeah meanwhile when
you were a kid and you were starting
comedy you're like how did he get that
role i wonder how many times he
auditioned yeah if people at home really
knew that after a while you just
developed relationships i went to an
audition last week and there was a bunch
of old italians in there they were
talking about hollywood in the 80s and
90s and they were talking about when
casting people in the old days recall
you go
i didn't book this like i like you know
how many people would want to book a
pilot
guess what
15 years ago i was in my house i'm about
to go get coke
i swear to god and i got a call from
julie ashton
at 6 45 at night she goes joy what are
you doing tonight i go nothing i got a
spot she goes
can you go to fox i forgot to cast a
part on the pilot nypd blue 2069.
she goes we'll negotiate in the morning
but i'm going to take care of you just
go and do this for me please and i went
and i had two lines and i fell and i got
shot and the pilot never got picked up
but that was one of many opportunities
that people just called me up that's how
it was i think i got like eight grand
for a [ __ ] phone call yeah the night
before you know how much i needed that
[ __ ] eight grand
so if you put the work in
somewhere along the line could just
because you want something doesn't mean
you'll get that but you'll get something
else if you put the work in
can i tell you another
this is and this is a little
why you should be nice to people okay
so if you twist that it'll start on the
side or right here another little knob
it'll stop falling off why can't you do
it
why can you be nice and do it for me
like that thank you
so i was a doorman right at the comedy
store and this lady
was hanging up like walking around the
parking lot and i go hey lady
what you need anything she goes i hate
this club they're always so rude because
remember back then when like the harris
peed they were so [ __ ] rude
yeah two of those guys
she didn't know what to do so i go you
know what
i'll get you in so i snuck around the
back you're right i got her a seat and
then i didn't have any money at the time
but she looked like somebody with power
and she seemed nice so i go i i got her
a wine
she sat there she saw whoever she needed
to see and she afterwards she goes she
was an agent at gersh at the time and
she goes uh what's your name i go my
name is bobby lee right
two years later i'm testing for mad tv
and she attended
she's now an executive and she attended
my
my test
my audition
and she said afterwards that she was
only there for me to get my job
because i was so nice to her two years
before that night yeah
it like it was the weirdest cosmic
experience i mean i got to that point by
doing 12 auditions and i i mean i you
know i mean i did the work but that last
final thing that lady was just sitting
there you know i mean
and you everything helps you know and
like she really
that was amazing it was a big lesson to
just be nice to everyone you [ __ ]
know
you see
is it hard for you i growing up i used
to hate in school when there used to be
group projects i used to i used to
always think i'll just do it myself i
like i couldn't trust other people i
didn't like working with them
and hearing all you say like
even now like we had this guy kevin very
nice help us with the studio
it's gotten to the point where
especially i don't even know if it's his
town but
you start becoming like a little bit
wary of people who are trying to be nice
or or want to work with you
and
it's nice to hear that not everybody is
is out like there are people actually
trying to help and being nice and it's
like did it take you a while to get to
that place of accepting help and working
with other people
well i mean i
i think maybe it's an innate thing that
you're born with i really don't it's not
something that you consciously decide in
my head i'm like
you just
feel it in your heart to be nice and
then you are you mean i mean let me tell
you something i've had years where i was
a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i didn't help
anybody i mean i thought i was the [ __ ]
but you know what i've suffered i mean
there were some years after mad tv where
i was them
nobody wanted me for many years
and you you either go you know become
bitter and sad and angry
or you change and you become
a better person like your parents taught
you
you know so it's like i've decided to
just
be as nice as i can you know i've never
denied a photograph have you no yeah if
i'm at a restaurant before shows i do
like but when i get to a thing before a
show because i don't want everybody
taking pictures right yeah yeah yeah so
i do afterwards especially you're
walking through the showroom and right
there's some guy in the back yeah yeah
you have to do them afterwards of course
but if you're at a restaurant right and
somebody goes can i get a photo or a
waiter or you would say yes right
because there's a lot of [ __ ]
that won't right it's like i'm you know
if somebody wants to talk to me about
something i will talk
you know i mean if they ask me hey how
did this you know i like this sketch
i'll talk to them about it even though
i don't want to you know i mean but it's
like
yeah i feel like i've changed and i'm
more available you know i mean for stuff
like that i think you have to be
i mean when i started in denver the big
thing that they had was running the
light
and i couldn't figure it out at first i
went home on that bus a couple nights
and i thought about it it's weird even
at the store today as soon as the light
gets out i get off
and people always say to me you know you
have a couple few minutes after that i
don't care
because i want people to understand how
i am you know what the first thing i do
when i get home is from the road
when i pull up in front of my house i go
upstairs
i take my luggage i throw the clothes in
i put my sleep apnea mask on i go and i
take a shower and i come out you know
what the next thing i do is i write a
check with a commission
and i send it the next day
because i don't want no [ __ ] problems
with my money okay when i got money i
don't want you taking [ __ ] 30 days to
mail me a [ __ ] check yeah i send you
your [ __ ] money that's a respect i
give people i tell them when they go wow
i gotta check from you teresa oregon you
know why
because i don't want no misunderstanding
with my [ __ ] money either so when you
have your money i don't want it in your
[ __ ] pocket to get interest for three
weeks mail me my [ __ ] money i don't
want to wait for the account on
wednesday because the first time i wait
for your account on wednesday i'm gonna
make you wait for my accountant he only
comes once a year
okay you don't want that do you no okay
i don't wait for accounts send me my
[ __ ] money on thursday and i'll send
you a [ __ ] check yeah i don't give a
[ __ ] if you don't put the check in the
bank don't
you know what i was doing the last
couple years when i booked a job i'd
show up there and give him the
commission before the job was even shot
don't touch my money don't touch my
money i don't want the 10 days then the
10 you got by the time i get the check
it's 25 days later why because you guys
want interest on what 800
just give me the [ __ ] money what do
you do in a situation at a club and you
know that you did better then you know i
mean they say you did
you know what i mean in terms of money
like do you say things or did you just
let it go in the beginning i got pissed
and then i realized why i paid my agent
and even though i go home on that flight
a little pissed like i got smacked in
the face
first thing i do when i get home is i
[ __ ] go off on my agent and go get me
my [ __ ] money right now
in fact here's my i email him with my
bank account
just time to deposit the money i don't
even [ __ ] around it's already so when
they call me back and they go i already
i email i assume the clothes
you rip me off i assume the clothes like
i'm about to work at clubbing a few
weeks ago
that this was the only club that came to
me right now in charlotte right now you
want me to tell you what the numbers are
for the week in charlotte
i'll tell you right now
just so you know how i sell you're gonna
die okay
because i got no reason to lie to
anybody just so people go oh well joey
[ __ ] lied or
whatever this is what i have
trash
let's see where the [ __ ] is this now
with my luck
it's not in this game no it's not
because i i i'll erase the other thing i
got 70 for the first show
thursday night
i got uh 118 or something i got 700
tickets sold i think 60 for the first
show on saturday you know what the
second show is on saturday what 256.
amazing already already just i always
sell out saturday late show first that
goes first you know what this club toner
came to me and said
man your saturday late show's looking
bad i just let him i didn't say nothing
you know me i let him fall into his own
trap yeah
i said really i go what are you telling
me
you've only got like 30 seconds over the
last show
he goes so i had to do a groupon two for
one
but don't worry it'll be back tomorrow
night
and i looked him straight in the face
and i said
i'm sure it will be
and this guy thought he had me till
monday and i [ __ ] called every i
called the higher-ups i called everybody
and go
because i got all those emails i got
those emails i sent them to the [ __ ]
office
and i said listen this guy's not getting
away with this and sure enough there was
a mistake
because there always is
yeah i'm cowardly when it comes to that
no i just don't get in people's faces i
just like no if they i let the jewel
they say you know hey and i know
different i don't say nothing because
i feel like if i make a sting that
they'll never have me back there well
[ __ ] it but i'm getting my money
i don't give a [ __ ] if you don't i don't
want to do a deal i don't listen
why would you want to deal with me if
i'm [ __ ] your money ever again give
my money i won't ever come back here
again you go [ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourself if you're [ __ ] me on
money we know now we could go into a
room right now and we could tell you
what's in that room and be off by 20.
and we know our own trends we're
economists we know yeah listen for you
to have a great weekend you gotta have
150 people in there on a thursday night
with the pictures from twitter and stuff
you'll pack it up if you have 70 people
on thursdays it's going to be a rough
weekend you know what i'm saying it's
monday i'm not worried about your radio
blah blah blah
but don't come to me and tell me that
that is another thing that's on a
saturday show you made a big mistake
and i got every dime yeah i got every
time you're a [ __ ] cuban jew i got
every dime white torment you in fact
they even sent the guy a shirt the agent
sent the guy a shirt that said what
would joey diaz do
really
yeah we know i'm not in business to get
robbed i don't want to rob you and i
don't want you robbing me all right
there's 20 chairs you don't call
but even that that's [ __ ] 200 it's
400.
if you get a shot deal yeah 20 chairs at
20 20 times 20 is 400.
i think i got buzzed from the thing
that's okay just drink some water
i think i got buzzed a little bit from
the thing
nah you're fine are you sure yeah
because i'm sweating i'm sweating and
stuff oh it's hot in here oh i'm
sweating like [ __ ] uh lee the other
day when i show them they hit acid
what's this what's tony bennett all
about
it's just a nice little sweet song to
calm things down
we're almost in the home stretch here
look at you in h town on valentine's day
and [ __ ] [ __ ] you know that because i
know everything
hey can i plug a couple of things man
you can plug whatever you want but wait
till the end of the show you don't need
to plug it now i'm gonna plug it forward
you're a [ __ ] stop brother
what's going on
just sitting here relaxing let's smoke
some more pot here let me open up the
door get some air in here
so how you doing bobby
yeah
yep
yeah
as soon as we open the door police siren
shows up you know what i'm saying this
is a nice place man very nice
i got this on the way back i was walking
with the baby and the guy came on he
goes hey you came in here for an office
about a year ago you still interested we
got an office opened up
so we were going to do what i called
kevin
and i said can you just come in and give
us some advice in the office this
[ __ ] came in here and took over
yeah the building [ __ ] oh this brick
right here you they did that kevin did
that he hung the tv we had the tv
obviously
everything
kevin helped uh my man hear lee hang the
cameras
it's something that you go home and
you're like why is somebody being so
nice and after being around them i get
it
i get it you know there's some people
who are just genuinely nice in this town
and we don't expect it right because we
know it always comes with something you
know what i'm saying my card's always up
or something yeah it comes with a by the
way of a man we want you to do this gig
or something whatever he's just been
really cool i'm trying to find a way to
pay him back but i know he's one of
those guys that uh
he puts it in the karma box
yeah you know some people fill up the
karma box do you believe do you believe
in karma yes i do i've lived it i'm
living proof of karma yeah but can i ask
you something then
though how come like um
like guys like george w bush nothing bad
happens to him something bad happens to
him we just don't know it
no he's playing golf and stuff something
bad happens to him every day when he has
to face himself at the end of the night
that's when karma shows up yeah but he
like started a bunch of illegal wars and
a lot of people died and stuff right
he'll pay for it he deserves aids and
stuff at some point it's so like i
remember when i when i robbed this guy
and i
you're never getting back into that
right now and i robbed 18-5
like what i made from the scam was 18-5
you know what i ended up paying the
attorney 18 000. i never forget that
looking at the bills and going well you
got caught i made 500 bucks
like this is god sending me a bill like
i made fun like god making me realize
that i made 500 for two years of my life
because i know you've beaten a man with
a pipe before no no i didn't beat nobody
with nobody you know you've never beaten
anybody with a power before though yeah
i think you have no no no yeah yeah no
no no you told me one time that you've
been a man with a pipe i must have
smacked them with a two by four yeah
yeah yeah right that's a big you've
never like beaten the guy to almost dead
with the pipe before no you yes you have
no i haven't no i haven't you got the
right yeah you're the wrong guy yeah
you've never violently attacked anybody
before not with a pipe no with what
i got into fights some guy jumped me and
he had a two by four i took it from him
hit him with him one time yeah yeah i
hit a guy with a heineken bottle when i
was 18. he was a man
yeah he was a [ __ ] man you know he
was a real [ __ ] man he had another
friend who was a man and we were scared
uh
but you've never taken a pipe out of
your car and beaten a man with it i'm
taking a pipe out like remember down in
la jolla when those guys are looking for
me and i threw the [ __ ] cue ball oh
yeah do you remember like i know how to
get you rattled nobody could rattle you
like me i'd rather you were you there
that night where joe rogan we went to
the strip club
no
oh
cause joe rogan didn't talk to me for
years after that
because he was headlighting and then we
went we went to a stripper i thought you
were there
and then there was these gang members
with tattoos on their faces i didn't
know anybody i was young and joke goes
let's get out of here and we're with
other comics i thought you were there
and i go no don't be a [ __ ]
right because they were like eyeing us
and stuff and then years later i had to
apologize to joe i go i know we almost
died
i'm sorry
all right i i feel funny i got to get
out of here
why what's up i feel dizzy or something
man
i drank it nothing happened i have some
red bull nothing happened after the deal
have some red bull and some water how's
that what i like earlier i said that i
sucked the guys did did i say that yes
you did okay that's okay nothing wrong
with that i feel like it's been weird
ever since then
what was what was worse the dick or
[ __ ]
what [ __ ] like when you're just
licking a girl's [ __ ]
i they dig for sure
i'm not gay dude
yeah but i was thinking about it the
other day have you ever sucked a dick no
you've never nope not even once no you
would think about it
but i was i was thinking about a couple
like last week for girls it just must be
like
hard skin like that's all like it
doesn't what like it doesn't it doesn't
taste like anything like if you take a
jacket that's why you should try it
you just said it was worse than eating
ass i'm not gonna do it if it's worse
than anything yeah because it's like
there's like social implications and
it's like i don't want to be doing this
you know
you're drunk with your friend
listen to me man when i was a kid
i was small
i was this asian kid but i had a sexual
a sexual drive but i grew up in a
predominantly white neighborhood in my
high school was 99.9 white and none of
those girls want anything to do with me
you know i always been always a dirty
korean
you know i mean my father is from um my
father was a street guy
my father during the korean war used to
hustle he never went to school he was in
gangs and stuff and then he joined the
korean military but my dad was a hoodlum
so i'm from
you know i mean korean trash almost you
know what i mean
like you know so it's like and then we
my dad works hard and we live in the
suburbs but i'm around all these you
know white girls and stuff they don't
want nothing to do with me so it's like
you know you get drunk you're 15 16
and your friend pulls out his penis you
know i didn't
i made a mistake no you're very sexual
you were highly sexual
and i used to go to those like f street
in san diego we had those f street
bookstores and they used to have those
um masturbation booths
you remember those are you sneaking you
go in the back and the floor's sticky it
makes the sound
are they people having live sex or no
you would close the door
you close the door and then you put you
know i mean dollar bills or quarters in
right or
f street had these tokens you either go
to the front right you know give them 40
bucks and then they give you tokens and
you put the tokens and then there's a
button there's two buttons like you know
i mean changing channels and they were
always like the puddle of comma you know
do you have to stick your fingers in cup
puddle of coffee was this before the
internet or why would you go there yeah
this is the night late 80s
right
jesus so people was that no they had
vcrs by then right yeah but i went to
them yeah i was a kid he was a kid i was
19. i'm not going to go home to my
parents house yeah what i had when i was
a kid was you go in
and there was a bed in the middle
where
26 that was his number yeah yeah
there was a bed in the middle and there
was a guy [ __ ] like this fat chick
and then live live then there'd be
windows all around on 42nd street same
thing you walked in you locked the door
you put talking the window would slide
up yeah and then there was the ones that
had the plexiglass that you just watched
and people would [ __ ] you could look
around and see the guys jerking off like
bad's banging it's [ __ ] creepy man
what did you ever jerk off in those oh
[ __ ] yeah when i was 15 yeah yeah you
have to you don't know you don't know
that's the first time you see like
somebody actually [ __ ] in front and
you could smell a [ __ ]
yeah you could say let you win at 15.
they didn't give a [ __ ] they weren't
proof that's probably in the 70s right
that's the 70s man they didn't proof yet
jesus christ now you'd walk in and
there'd be a great uh there'd be a
[ __ ] janitor and he'd go into every
room when the door would open and
somebody would walk out before he'd go
in there he'd go in and drop them up and
[ __ ] mop and put it back in with all
sperm and [ __ ] and then you go in there
put and you had to be careful what you
touched
and they'd have sex in front i think i
did it twice guys you know just being
young and stupid
but then there was times i was in the
city i just go in there just to see what
was going on just to see the
the desperation like i would walk by
that nine in the morning and see 20
people like hasidic jews
yeah walking out and going why are you
[ __ ] you know they walk out real fast
high seas and you know these are people
that
it's weird when people let their
religious beliefs suppress their sexual
that's why all these [ __ ] politicians
when they whenever when somebody tells
me they're a christian all of a sudden i
see them in the bedroom [ __ ] their
wife in the ass and smacking them
because they're really horny [ __ ]
devils it's really weird like i was
really horny when i was a kid and then
once i realized i couldn't get [ __ ]
like the rest of my friends i let that
emotion go in a way and i got like
that's exactly what it is that's exactly
what i went through and i would say you
know what instead of going after women
i'll just masturbate i'll just go home
and masturbate that'll be the easy thing
i don't have to talk to them or nothing
but then like in 87 the cocaine turned
me
like once
right before i got locked up
cocaine flipped on me and i got really
sexual with the coke like i could go all
night and put coke in their feet but you
got girls then then yeah yeah you
started getting girls girls yeah you
would always have a girl with coke and
you eat that [ __ ] with coconut would it
bum you out that it was only when they
when you had coke because i went through
a thing where i only hooked up with
girls when we were drinking and they
used to bum me out i'm like [ __ ] they
have to be drunk in those days i didn't
care i didn't care how i got [ __ ]
because i had been suppressed for so
long yeah i wasn't like the rest of my
friends my friends would come to me and
say i got [ __ ] last week down the shore
for me i'd get a victim once a month
growing up or once every six months but
i really never had a girlfriend
and i didn't have the sexual escapades
my friends were having that 21 and 22. i
never heard of stuff like that until i
left new jersey i had my first threesome
at 35
36 and it was one of the worst things of
my life yeah
two girls and one guy two girls you've
never done a threesome with two guys one
girl no no i have a couple times looking
at another guy what is that comics i did
it with mike burton
you know who mike burton is no mike
burns is a stand-up yeah yeah he's still
around yeah yeah yeah yeah mike burton
and a feature the girl i can't say her
name because she's still around and we
do the threesome and um
he was so selfish
because you know i mean he would pull
her up to his side of the bed and i
don't want to touch him so you know what
i ended up doing going to the side a bit
and just masturbating watching them and
we also can i just say something we all
laughed
so much it was like the funnest sex i've
ever really ever had
you know and i did it with aaron cater
and brian etheridge once in vegas too
that three that was a five seven i was
gonna say where's that fivesome
girls
where did you meet the two girls dude um
this is so gross
so um you know what you know steve
saripa yeah so schrippa riviera yeah so
he calls me and goes
because dice used to call me ching
right
so so steve stripper used to call me
ching right as is chi-ching that's what
they used to say not racial but i know
it was racial so you're hing i go hey
we're doing this midnight dirty show i
want you to headline i'd never headline
before so brian etheridge and aaron
cater were open micros at the time did
we'll drive you i mean we'd love to see
that right so they drove me out there so
we're on las vegas boulevard these two
sisters drive by right and brian ethers
is driving and the two sisters roll down
the window and they go you're cute
not to brian because he's the ugliest
white dude i've ever seen or me if they
were saying decatur kate is a [ __ ]
cute boy yeah good looking kid right
cater runs out of the car jumps into
this [ __ ] truck they drive out into
the sunset right and me and brian are
[ __ ] mad all right so then we get to
the riviera i go brian you go do your
own thing i have to concentrate right on
my set list or whatever so then midnight
i'm literally on stage and i see brian
and aaron bring in these two sisters one
was like a 300 pound white lit girl and
the other one was 80 pounds but they
were sisters and they were missing teeth
but you know at the time you know i need
you know so anyway after the show aaron
goes hey
don't do us
so let's go to the room so we're in the
room and
so you know you're no condom either you
know
i know so we were doing it you know
doing it and doing it and then all of a
sudden like three hours later i'm with
the fat one and aaron's with this skinny
one i don't know what brian is
i don't know where brian is
so i look around the room i don't know
what brian is maybe he's in the bathroom
you know he's not in the bathroom
so i keep doing i'm doing but doggy
style with this fat one
and i feel something tickling my
butthole
it was like a feather you know what i
mean i turn around
not no one's there
so it was like paranormal
you know what i mean i thought that was
like a paranormal ghost tickling your
butt yeah yeah yeah yeah
but then like i keep going and i find i
i definitely feel something you're like
object like something you know i mean
and i look down
brian had crawled underneath my body
and he was eating her [ __ ]
while i'm having sex with her now let me
tell you something
let me tell you something you have to
imagine what is on his face now at this
point you know my little goop juice
he's got [ __ ] juice fat juice you know
what i mean mixed together you know what
i mean who knows what kind of you know
why not just go for the [ __ ] what
does he i don't know but he goes she
likes it she likes it i don't like it
because it's like
his chin is rubbing against my taint i
don't like it it's weird
right i can't get hard
so
it gets worse
so i decided to power fogger
right so i go
you know how you do it
i'm not gonna get in trouble for the
same time power [ __ ] nobody in ten years
yeah all right
like that you know what i mean and you
know i slipped out right so i tried to
stick it back in and but brian had moved
up right and it rubbed against his eye
right so then we all disbanded you know
i mean because like he screamed you know
what i mean
and like what we got to fight
like why are you down there you know i
mean you purposely i didn't purposely
you know
so then afterwards we go to breakfast
so i'm taking these two girls off for
breakfast erin's there
and we're talking laughing i just can't
wait to go to sleep and i look at brian
from across the table his left eye
completely closed with a yellow film
a yellow film had closed it shut like an
adhesive
right
i go dude we gotta go to the [ __ ]
hospital
because no i'm good i go no you're not
good you can't [ __ ] see out of that
eye it's like infected it's red it's
like pulsing you know
which is his [ __ ] fault right so then
we go to the [ __ ] um
hospital
right now we're no sleep you know what i
mean it's a disaster
right
and we're i'm in there with them you
know i mean with them we're like what
are we gonna say
right
he goes i'll just make something up so
the doctor goes what happened and he
goes he skull [ __ ] me
he points at me i skull [ __ ] them
you kind of did
yeah but not you know did you have him
check your dick because like what was on
your dick that made his eye close up
dude it was not just my dick the jute
all kinds of stuff man you don't [ __ ]
listen dude i can't believe my i just i
went to the doctor two weeks ago
and i got all tested my shit's clean dog
all right
nothing i have no diseases you know what
i mean no diabetes nothing you're pretty
serious with this girl now you like i
love it i could tell you okay so check
it out man how long have you been with
her three years oh two and a half years
yeah yeah yeah
i'm in love with my girlfriend she we
live together we have three cats
um we have a podcast together called
tiger belly okay and it's doing well
and uh i just couldn't imagine a better
life right now man where'd you meet her
tinder dude
dude i couldn't even believe three years
ago like two and a half years ago she
swiped right we matched well first of
all i had two nightmare tinder before
that you know
uh one of the girls
all her photos was just off her face
and she looked like natalie portman but
then when i picked her up she had
michael chiklis's body like worse than
yours
like it was just a complete circle but
her face was really cute
really good face
and the other one was a comedian i want
to get into that wait are you on tinder
were you on tinder as bobby lee yeah
that's the best way you know stone the
street from modern family
i got him on it too
after my success eric snake he's not fat
he's just chubby dude
the stone street i went to his house i
got him on tinder i've got
created a profile together right it's
the best if you're a celebrity
right
it is because imagine here's the thing
with tinder all right
when you and i we live our lives we wake
up we have our routines we go to our
coffee shop right we have you know me
our errands then we do our show at the
club but you have to imagine
people even in la or in long beach or
whatever pasadena they have their own
lives they can't make it to the comedy
club right so it's like you're never
gonna run into them right but the tinder
it it just
you know you just have more branches out
there
and kalila was always a fan of mine
right but we just she never just came to
my shows
and so
i met her for coffee and as soon as i
sat down and we we had coffee together i
just i remember going [ __ ]
in my head because i knew i'm in a
relationship
the first time i met her
i already knew that this was gonna be a
thing you know you know you can tell
when you meet somebody
you just look in their eye go yeah this
is gonna be a [ __ ] thing
it's just there's a connection and uh
yeah we're you know
yeah we're together and we have a really
good
um connection and you know we've had
we've had we've had our problems
everybody does yeah it's hard
relationships
what does she do for a living oh she's a
comedian okay yes well no she stopped
doing that but she um i don't want to
get into it but she has a heart
situation okay she has a physical
situation and she can't work right now
so instead of doing you know i mean we
decided to do a podcast together so that
we can create maybe a business together
you know
and it's going really well
so you look good you look healthy
everything 14 [ __ ] years sobriety
yeah it seemed like yeah how many doors
opened for you after you got sober it
took me years to
but how different is your life life
from the drug that killed me for eight
years i still smoke pot yeah that's fine
i don't take pills i still smoke my pot
my friend gave me anxiety pills if i
can't sleep after a plane i'll take one
to help me go to bed i never really
drink i i was never really a big drinker
i smoked my pot and that's it but the
drug that killed me
eight years i can't tell you how many
doors have opened for me yeah but you
know why it helped for me is because of
the fact that
when i got sober what helped was
show business
didn't become my life
right
for many years show business was number
one
right and my mood and my livelihood and
how i felt my about myself was directly
related to how i was doing my career
okay
and as soon as i got sober that no
longer was the case you know i want to
live a life
you know and so
you know when my friends book [ __ ] you
know i don't go [ __ ] him
i go congratulations yeah when you see
guys succeed it doesn't really affect me
they're like ken jung you know i mean he
was my doctor when i got sober you know
i mean he he helped me get through my
detox
you know and he
is a bigger star than me and i'm fine
with it you know and a lot of people
come up to me and they go
they go oh you you know you jealous of
ken's success no
why would you be why would i be he's a
talented guy
and
i'm fine with it
those people that hate
and you know the people that naturally
hate you could see them when you first
got mad tv and you walked into the
comedy store some people gave you a big
hug
and there was some people who gave you a
[ __ ] michael corleone fredo hug
and you felt it you're jesus christ why
are you like this
and that you know and that's
going back to what that jerk-off said
about you that night that you're just an
actor guy that's
even that day on the tweet with me he
was saying he said that i was on his
jock when he got his deal i wasn't even
at the store when he got his deal you
know i remember he got beat up in san
diego when he went to he got some water
and he got me
or something i remember all that [ __ ]
and i always felt kind of bad for him so
when he got that attitude towards me i
was like i just left it alone
it's like when comics [ __ ] say i got
a deal who gives a [ __ ] everyone
eventually gets one you know what i mean
it's like
people take these things and they think
that it makes them who they are
and so what did you have to do to stop
making that the most important thing in
your life well when you when i was
because out drugs was killing me and i
realized that my life was more important
and my family was more important it
shifts your perspective right
right so what you you were talking at
the start of the podcast about you won't
do certain rooms back then would you
have said that to those people what do
you mean would you have told the manager
at the kansas city no i don't want to do
your roaming i wasn't even doing i was
so drugged out i wasn't even headlining
then i only headlined because i was
still on mad tv
i only headlined after matt tv was
cancelled in a year in i realized that
you know i wasn't going to be the tv
star that i thought i was going to be
and that's when
i started doing the road and it saved my
life
i got to tell you the truth for me to
get sober
i had to do something i had to do
something i had forgotten about i had to
put myself
i i
i thought that those
10 years i had been in hollywood
that i was very passive with people and
i wasn't the man like i didn't remember
what it was like to be a man and i
remember like three months before
getting sober i'm like
i want to just be a man again bobby lee
i have to get the respect of being a man
again i'm a man why is this happening to
me if you're a man you shouldn't be
caught up in these type predictions and
this type of [ __ ]
so i went back to get my character like
who i was when i was 13 when people go
hey you want to get iron i could go [ __ ]
your mother i'm not getting high like i
went back to look for that like
something interesting happened to me i
did kill tony last monday night
and i was telling lee i watched the
comedians go on stage those young comics
to do a minute you know have you ever
done the show couple times yeah and you
see when people kill and you applaud for
them and i saw what my face used to look
like when i was doing comedy five years
that look of that eye of the tiger i
remember when you killed for the first
time yeah and you killed for the first
time oh i'm missing you can't go home
you can't sleep please you nothing for
[ __ ] a week
heroin by the time that you will not
fall asleep so why isn't it as exciting
anymore
check it out check it out okay
i
didn't get any [ __ ] ever right until i
was 23 years old
okay
i used to go get you know i mean i could
i'd
go to a brothel in tijuana okay
when i was 23 years old i was a doormat
at the comedy store okay
this is in 1995.
and one saturday night the manager let
me um
host in front of a packed room
so i went up and i [ __ ] killed for
the first time
you know what happened not only did that
happen but that night a girl called
the [ __ ] club and says hi my name is
jennifer is bobby lee the comedian there
was a doorman that he went up is he
there fred burns gave me the [ __ ]
phone and she goes i just think it
really you're really cute and are you
single this and that no way yeah so i
swear to god three days later i'm in her
house in ocean
side california and i'm eating her posey
and i'm going
not only did i kill for the first time
but now i'm getting chicks it literally
was
the birth of me
someone called a i thought it was gonna
be like an agent to book you for
something they called because they
thought you were hot yeah and her name
was jennifer field
that was her name she was this cute
blonde white chick from ocean view side
california
i only see ocean view because that was
my first rehab when i was 16 but that
was also an ocean side but um yeah and i
went to her house and i remember it just
being a
a spiritual experience for me
so so
i mean you must have gotten laid other
times from comedy since then yeah i've
been killing it but my point though is
is that you know
it was the first time yeah in the first
time killing you know i mean and i it's
like
you know yeah i can i kill i guess now
when i'm on the road it's my audience
and i do well on stage but it does you
cannot capture that feeling for the
first time
you chase that it's like addiction yeah
you chase that feeling the reason why
we're still here 20 years later is we're
chasing that yeah yeah yeah it's a
[ __ ] tremendous
the first kill and the first time you
get on stage you cannot describe it you
cannot describe it to anybody
you cannot describe it it's just a
beautiful [ __ ] thing the adrenaline
oh my god that'll drop you know i was
telling them when you had line four
shows on sunday morning you saw
you're [ __ ] saw when you get on the
plane you're like why am i sore yeah cuz
i've been [ __ ] working yeah i'm
working i'm moving i'm changing
positions your feet are sinking in not
only [ __ ] that but [ __ ]
friday morning you gotta wake up at five
in the [ __ ] morning to do a press
tour you know what i mean and then like
you don't then you don't get any sleep
your diet's [ __ ] up you don't know
where to eat you know what means you eat
a hamburger at mcdonald's on the way to
the show i mean it's like it's not
easy
why are you looking can i have a drag of
a cigarette at least you can do whatever
you want are you
because it's like you know i mean that
you know i think i'm getting buzzed from
your thing
so maybe i'll smoke a cigarette and help
me smoke a little cigarette there never
killed nobody
but yeah i mean
it's tough but you know what guys can i
say this
anyone listening right now
i think the moral of the story is this
is that
joey and i a lot of people don't like me
you know i mean i have my haters you
know i have a lot of fans also and the
reason why i have the i have my
girlfriends beautiful and the reason why
i have all these things is not because
i'm unique or special it's because of
the fact that a long time ago
i did a scary thing which is choose to
do stand-up all right the first time you
go up
it's very scary like your heart's you
know i mean beating you're shaking you
know what i mean you convince yourself
don't do it
you know i had a friend randy who made
me do it the first night
you have to do it i'll never talk to you
again i went up there
and it's like literally jumping out of a
plane you know like
you're adrenaline you know i mean and i
just remembered making funny noises on
stage because i don't really have any
jokes so i went up and i went
right and i did that for three minutes
because i knew that i'd make randy laugh
right
and then afterwards people were like
that was [ __ ] weird right and then
like
a month later i did open mics at the
comedy store right and paulie saw me go
up and i did the same thing the noising
noises right and then i was just you
know no joke was just acting really
weird on stage and probably goes dude
you're [ __ ] weird brah
i go oh thanks he goes i want you to
open for me in vegas
and then dude i'm not kidding you
two months after that this is like three
or four months into comedy i opened for
him in front of 5 000 people at the top
of the river
you know what i mean but my point is is
this is that
i [ __ ]
did it
i walked through that fear you know i
mean and i religiously made myself do
something that was that scary
and i just really believe that if you
want to have a big life you have to take
big risks
you have to say [ __ ] it and just to go
for it you know i mean and i know you
you and i don't appreciate you know i
mean
that part of ourselves because it's just
innate in us and we we already did it
you know what i mean but it is a [ __ ]
crazy thing that we chose to even do
this in the [ __ ] first place
and look at what it's got us i mean you
talk about you know i mean you you're
being on set with tracy morgan and adam
sandler for that movie you know i mean
you know a couple years ago i was on the
dictator i did scenes with sir ben
kingsley and ed norton you know what i
mean and i'm like sitting on a couch
talking about i believe it when it's
happening when it's happening you're
like i'm gonna open i wasn't opening
like a cracker why is this guy yeah this
is great like ben kid's like hey um so
um when you tell me the law that line
you know just slow it down a bit so that
like you know and really connect and in
my head i'm like i can't [ __ ] believe
i i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm doing
here
like what the [ __ ] am i doing here i
don't even i never take a class i don't
know nothing
it's [ __ ]
right it's crazy
and and yet you know you you're in these
situations because
not because i'm talented or
but you are talented i'm not like isn't
don't you no no it's not it's not talent
that's what listen
best thing conor mcgregor has ever said
in his life this is not talent this is
an obsession
that's what it is obsession but don't
you think that your obsession creates
talent no stand up dude i never thought
i had talent i don't know what the [ __ ]
people are talking about it's what it is
is this it's repetition all right when
you do something enough
eventually what happens is the fear
and the and the fear of failing goes
away because you failed so many times
that you inevitably grow a thick skin
you do
so then eventually bombing doesn't
destroy you as much and then eventually
you're kind of immune to it i mean it
hurts a little bit you hate it but it
doesn't like when you go home you're
watching cnn and you you forget about it
right but it's like you eventually it's
just repetition and walking through fear
and as if you fail enough
you become
immune to it and then when you become
immune to it you're yourself
yeah but there's there's a lot of people
who have been doing open mics for 10 20
years whatever
i'm not going to say that you're like
the mount rushmore of comedy but you
have there has to be some talent
involved in it
you here's the thing is is that i i will
agree this i will agree with this i can
i know i know how comedy is supposed to
work
like when you when i when i was a kid i
used to watch george carlin
you would watch him and go
okay i see you know i mean you you laugh
and then you kind of think why did i
laugh at that
because you know you thought he was
saying this and then he said that you
know means it was a switch or whatever
so you you learn you know as a kid you
analyze like why a joke works but it's
like
i'm [ __ ] you know i
i'm not a talented i really think and
i've thought this for a while that and
actually denzel had a line about this in
uh gangs king of gangsmen or whatever it
was um where he said like the loudest
person in the room is the weakest one in
the room i think
that if you think you're good at
something you're probably not great at
it and if you think you're terrible like
what you think you're terrible at it's
because you have so much pride or so
much
so much love for it that it's never
going to be good enough even when it is
i laugh
every movie when i get on every movie
and i do a take i giggle inside
yeah like when they're like all right
you're ready for your scene and i walk
out on set and people come up to me like
mr diaz are you okay i'm like this poor
bastard
you know yeah people i don't even know
how i got here
like how did i get hired for this [ __ ]
if these people knew that
20 years ago i was crawling through a
[ __ ] window to steal somebody's blow
but they only [ __ ] knew like i can't
believe i'm on this [ __ ] set with
these nice white people and people with
a lip brush taking lint off my shirt and
trying to make me look nice and you're
like why
yeah when i was on animal practice right
i would show up an hour early like how
come you hurt her earlier because i
can't [ __ ] believe you even want me
in this yeah i can't believe you i don't
want to get fired
you know what i mean you can't believe i
can't believe it i'm i'm doing things
with a monkey
it was like a monkey one time i had to
do a dialogue see with the monkey and
the camera's on me but it has the back
of the monkey's head and i'm killing it
like i'm like and then they're like we
have to do it again because the monkeys
had moved and i'm like and they're like
we're so sorry i gotta [ __ ] it
yeah i mean i'm doing a scene with a
monkey
like this is not supposed to ever happen
i'm supposed to be dead
i don't like when i see people who take
[ __ ] seriously in this business yeah it
drives me crazy what do you mean by
taking when i go on the set and like
like i was on a set with this really so
so-called famous direct on a tv show tv
show sucked
and the director was old and he was out
of [ __ ] touch
but still in hollywood he counted for
something
and i get that he was blasting music
like it was the loudest music i ever
heard on set
in my world a star does that you know
what i'm saying like brad pitt could do
that like you know
the direct i go what's going on they're
like the world director is good friends
with bruce springsteen so he likes to
listen to him loud [ __ ] that punk-ass
[ __ ] yeah like that said it was misery
for me
because there was ego so much ego all
the way on the way up you know what i'm
saying
there was so much ego that i did a
commercial once with it you know you
could always if i could tell who the
director is by his outfit yeah
you did a commercial who was the
director
i don't know what his name was oh but it
was uncomfortable very uncomfortable i
got into an argument with him and he
never messed with me again throughout
the whole production was it wasn't joe
pitka was it
no that's my boy you love joe pitch
listen he's the guy that that books a
lot of commercials or something no he's
a director he's like he did like the
beau knows campaign he did he's supposed
to be like the spielberg of joe pitka
directed me in the taco bell commercial
i did with the dog oh you did yeah yeah
yeah he had a company yeah he put me in
three commercials then dude yeah you
made a lot of money yeah yeah i did
commercial you know what he used to say
to me he used to call me pan phase [ __ ]
joe pick you got that [ __ ] he [ __ ]
told a [ __ ] girl
that was he had hired
you have [ __ ] hair
you look like a [ __ ] he was crazy he
was [ __ ] crazy and he was the only
man that i ever worked for where
literally i was scared shitless
24 7. like i remember like
you i did a commercial for him and i go
i'll never work for him again
and then like eight years later i get a
call joe wants because it was when i was
on my tv he goes he wants to do another
ibm commercial i go you know what i
could handle it
because you know i've already done it
you know what i mean i could get as soon
as i said that's honest i literally pee
was coming out of my penis big guy right
yeah he's tall he has white hair yeah
big guy he retired he was a legend like
he was legend the best commercial
director of all time all right let me
tell you his solid with your uncle joey
yeah he hired me for the first taco bell
commercial with the dog yeah it was a
miami commercial i got the call back it
was shooting on
the 3rd of july 4th of july 5th of july
i get down the 3rd of july and they go
amen
they cut the commercial but joe wants
you to hang out here for the three days
and they're still going to pay you
oh my god okay i said okay
well day one i eat i don't say nothing
i'm very happy just to be on this set
it's day two
during lunch you know we're doing our
thing yeah doing joey you know some guys
are [ __ ] with me i'm [ __ ] with
them he heard my voice
and he came over to me after lunch he
goes
stick around today i'm gonna put you in
this [ __ ] commercial
because they were like if you want to
leave at five that's your eight hours
but if you want to stay till midnight
you can stay come in there we'll pay you
the overtime just don't stay out of our
way that's what this is 97 when
commercials were still commercials where
you could get rich off a [ __ ]
commercial
and
the next day he came up to me he goes
i'm gonna put you in the scene i don't
give a [ __ ]
and he put me in the scene like did it
and six weeks later i got a call from
the actor
there was three stand-ups in that on
that set
i was a principal the other guy was a
principal and the other guy was an extra
the guy that was the top principal
called me and he goes did you get your
letter from
taco bell i go no and he goes yeah i got
my letter they didn't pick me up they're
probably not gonna pick you up either
and they picked you up they picked me up
and the extra got picked up because the
extra had contact with me so in an extra
has contract with a principal he
automatically becomes a principal so
every time i saw that comic he did
everything but suck my dick
because i told him just stick next to me
we're going to get this commercial
together
so he jumped i go get the thing and
shine my shoes yeah and he was shining
my shoes during the commercial so he
became a principal
so every time i see that guy till today
he stops what he's doing and he comes
over and gives me a big hug
and that was joe pick he put me in there
i want to say something that i want to
apologize for what i said earlier about
joe pick no seriously
he did call me those things right but i
wanted to say this i
he gave me a commercial once where i
made 350 thousand dollars
yeah it was a campaign for ibm
and i um i want to apologize to joe
thank you so much for that you know i
mean i wasn't comfortable during your
sets because i'm on your on your set
because i felt intimidated but i just
want to thank you for putting me in your
commercials and i really apologize he
put me in three [ __ ] yeah i want to
apologize you're the best
and that's it you know what your [ __ ]
marijuana smoke got into my mind let me
do these things okay let me give some
shout outs brian nelson paranormal diane
matteo
julio villalobos villa lobos chris
mcdougan andrew nelson levar michaels
and joey zaza tweets
look at you sexy [ __ ] bobby
lee's gonna be at the
improv in houston texas
february 12th to the 14th that's
valentine's day [ __ ] i'm going to be
at the charlotte comedy zone this
weekend
and next week i'm at saint louis
helium i'm sorry if i got your height
and i didn't mean to do that no that's
fine i'm totally fine
i'm totally fine what's up with you lisa
cox are you happy for the new office i'm
doing yeah i'm doing great i have a
tomorrow a new episode of life in
neutral with johnny rock all right and
uh yeah i'm just doing great i'm really
happy about this it's uh
it's it's so like when people
hearing you talk about all the nice
things that people did for you
this is the night this this is the
nicest thing that anyone's done for me
this is the thing oh
man
what no i mean i mean
no but it's
this is and the way you guys i mean it's
it's a different thing but for me are
you going to cry right now no
who knows but
like coming out and doing
this part like podcasting
in november it was two years that i've
only done podcasting
and it's it's i'm now where like i
where you guys were i don't know how
many years in
but it's
it's nice to see those nice things and
and joe when when joey takes me out to
dinner
it's it's we went to jerry's deli a few
weeks ago a week ago and i had a road i
had a roast beef sandwich it was just it
it's uh
it's nice and it's nice to see that you
guys remember it these many years later
like when you
when you guys see dorman that when you
were a doorman like do you go over and
give them a hug
yeah i'll hug them but i talk to them i
talk to the young guys yeah i talk to
them yeah i do their shows i try to get
involved listen man i can't tell you how
good andrew dice clay was to me
and to bobby lee i can't tell you how
nice paul mooney was to me you know how
many j you know how many stakes joe
rogan has brought me you got any idea
how many fifty dollar stakes that kid
has bought me
more than my mother i've been friends
with joe for 20 years my mother was only
around for 16. and my mother ate a lot
of steaks
do you understand me yeah so how can i
not buy everybody else's steak
you know how many [ __ ] lobster tails
how many times i went to eat with joe
and i had no money in my pocket and he'd
say man we're gonna get the seafood
tower
and i'd sit there and go seafood tower
i'll eat the ice
you know how it is just take you out so
you have to do that
you have to do that
i have to show the young guys you know
and i've said this on this show a
thousand times
the better i treat the young guys the
better my career and the better comedian
i will become that's
the [ __ ] thing right there dude
you know there's a book called the seven
spiritual laws of success it's by deepak
chopra
one of the laws of success
is you have to go out of your way and
help other people achieve success
that's one of the laws
why does he say that works
well there's a bunch of stuff that's in
there you have to meditate and all that
stuff but it's just
it's a karmic thing it's karma i believe
it's it's you know if you help people
achieve success it's selfless right it's
not about you and i think just
energy-wise it just comes back at you
dude you know you generate your own
energy
when you go to yoga you open your
chakras and you generate your own
energies you have kinetic energy and it
becomes potential energy not by you
sitting there like a putts but by doing
you know this podcast is about i bring a
thousand people on this podcast that
we've all had the same struggle
we've all started at a place where we
sucked
nobody liked us and then we saw the
evolution of men we saw how
there were people who didn't like you 10
years ago they'll suck your dick now
you follow me especially you on mad tv
right or wrong yeah there's people that
stopped talking to you after mad tv yeah
you learn about human but all you can do
is never get better
and keep looking at those younger guys
give them hugs
tell them they did great because this is
what happens when i see you and i go
you're hungry whatever a steak whatever
the [ __ ] you want it just makes me a
better comic and a better man
and that at the end of the week
every day you want to be a better
[ __ ] man i struggled in a drug
addiction for years where at the end of
the night i would cry myself to sleep
because this isn't the life i chose it
was the life i had been caught up in
but every day you struggle and when you
see somebody you help somebody out and
it doesn't have to be financially bobby
lee it could just be going up to
somebody and going bro that was a great
set yeah that was a great job
not me sitting in the back going
when bobby lee does a funny joke i don't
do another phenomena that just makes you
a [ __ ] jack off like everybody else
it's when i come up to you after a show
i don't know what's going on in your
mind you know what you might have just
killed but your mother's in the hospital
and me coming up to your own dog that's
a good [ __ ] joke when you get in your
car that might just bring a teeter you
are
that just might that's the [ __ ] that
makes comics
that's the way i was taught to be a
comedian but it wasn't the way i was
taught to be a comedian as how you
taught to be a [ __ ]
man becky how hot is becky
how about this backyard she's beautiful
yeah she's [ __ ] beautiful yeah
everybody in this room once said did you
see how far good she looked in those
pants
what am i gonna do by hitting on becky
you can't hit on everybody no
you can't these little things you have
to do as a man
and that's it you can't i'd love to
[ __ ] eat becky's [ __ ] and sniff it
and let her do jujitsu for an hour and
sit on my face that's what it's all
about you know what i'm saying
but you can't bang everybody that's part
of being a man you know
there's little things that we forget
we forget caparulo forgot
you know people forget you know what but
he was young
and i believe i believe he will change
and i will i believe that he'll get
better yeah he will he will because he
just lost it and it happens like i said
i lost it with the longest yard but it
went in the other direction
it didn't propel my ego it propelled my
sadness
because i let myself believe that a
movie was going to change my life yeah
you really let yourself we for a long
time we said when i get mad tv that i'll
show
it's not that you got sober and you
realize what you had and you helped the
younger guys when you took that writer
and then go come here i'm gonna put you
in the sketch yeah that thing and i
could see you i remember i got a call
one day going you and the other kid
would put me in a sketch yeah yeah and i
saw how you were i saw what you had
become on that show you were no longer
the kid in the corner now you had your
hands on you would do this yeah yeah you
know and i was proud of you i'm like
look at bobby lee calling me in for a
day's pay hugging me in front of
everybody you know bobby didn't just go
get the [ __ ] out he hugged me to make
let everybody know this is my brother he
eats the best off that crab service
[ __ ] he gets the sandwiches made
and that's what this whole thing is
about
it's not hating bobby when he's on stage
or hating this guy because he got a tv
show you have to be happy because
when i'm happy i know that i'm that much
closer
if i'm happy for bobby oh [ __ ] bobby got
a tv show that means my number's got to
be [ __ ] next because i was on that
same production line
we were on that same production line
that said
we were on the minty short production
line yeah and in my world that means
something when i didn't have an agent
when i didn't have a [ __ ] i didn't go
to montreal when i didn't get a half
hour special i didn't got nothing i had
something over anybody in this town
mitzi sure touched me
nobody else made me a regular i didn't
send a tape to nobody i auditioned for
that [ __ ] twice and she touched me so i
always knew i had something [ __ ] good
you needed her [ __ ] like others did
though
no idea you know a couple of comics that
we're friends with that ate her [ __ ]
and it's [ __ ] disgusting
i'm happy you drove up here i know you
have a podcast at 11. just don't steal
my white lighter that's the only thing
where's your white light this is yours
that's mine because if not i go to smoke
weed i got no like give me a cocktail i
love you man i love you that's great
thank you for the story see you again
brother nice to see you all right don't
forget as usual we got great sponsors
this one is no different this is their
first night with us and i gotta tell you
something
i'm very impressed i gave it to lisa i
gave it to damon
and damon installed it and he [ __ ]
loved it all right so let me uh
let me just read this to you and you
guys tell me what the there's a sound of
a package being delivered a friend's
coming over for dinner but it's also the
sign on somebody planning to rob you
blind
over 90 95 of home break-ins happen
during the day and burgers almost always
start by ringing your doorbell to see if
somebody's home before they pillage your
possessions okay
with the ring video doorbell you can see
and talk to anyone at your front door
from anywhere in the world using your
smartphone
so if somebody rings your doorbell and
let's say you're at yoga and you see
this guy you could get on there and tell
him you'll be home in an hour or ten
minutes or whatnot from anywhere okay
rings advanced motion detection alerts
you even if someone doesn't ring the
door bell it's like the caller id for
your home with the ring video doorbell
you can talk to delivery people and keep
an eye on your package if someone tries
to mess with it you'll get an instant
alert and hd video the whole thing it's
like having a neighborhood keep an eye
on your home 24 7 without the judgment
okay let me tell you something i used to
be a burglar
and this is the way to catch a burglar
anybody in your neighbor because it's
got motion detectors so turn the lights
on you connect this to your doorbell it
works in a thousand different ways
installing the ring video takes minutes
and it works either with your current
wiring or a built-in rechargeable
battery
put your mind at ease and protect your
home with the video doorbell time
magazine and usa today named one of
their top 10 gadgets
my listeners ready for this one people
listen to the podcast will get a free
expedited fedex shipping when you go to
ring.com church again
that's ring.com
church that's all you need to do we're
going to get you
fedex shipping free with the ring video
doorbell you're always home do me a
favor start by going to ring.com
church now but go to ring.com i want you
to do that favor see how this product
works you know i'm not really good with
gadgets i don't know if lee took a look
at it but just from what i was talking
to damon this bell is tremendous it's a
it goes right to your phone it looks it
looks like you're having like a facetime
video call and it goes right to your
phone and you can even pretend like you
are home oh i'm just stuck in the [ __ ]
i'm stuck in the shower and you come
back in 15 minutes okay it's tremendous
guys but do do me a favor go to ring.com
right now that's how it starts go to
ring.com read everything about it if you
like what you see
press in church
and bam you get free fedex shipping when
you go to ring.com
church that's ring.com
church and as usual i'd like to thank my
main sponsors over there at honor.com
always
always with the best product if it's not
the hemp force protein it's the t at i
mean they just have stuff every time i
go to that web page i'm in shock but i
always think you know me i'm an
old-fashioned guy the shroom tech sport
the shroom tech immune and the hem four
protein i live and die by those i live
and die with i had a force today after i
took mercy to the park i love that with
my banana my water a little a little bit
of sugar tremendous guys anyway don't
listen to me go to honor.com right now
if you see something you like go to the
box and press in church and get 10 off
your first order and this again like
ring and all my products get delivered
to your door okay this gets delivered to
your door if you want to get on the stay
on it program where they deliver
different packages to your door every
month just let them know they have the
standard program you get an additional
10 percent i'd like to thank our new
sponsor ring.com go to ring and see all
the advantages that doorbell gives you i
like to thank honor.com i'd like to
thank bobby lee and my main man lisa you
happy [ __ ] i'm thrilled thank you
buddy it was uh this is fun it's it's
gonna be a lot of fun in the studio
tremendous one we'll be back wednesday
afternoon
it's just me and lee and a calling show
i love you guys thank you very much and
as usual should we play some music a
little turntable music for you
let me do the ad real quick just to show
you guys what we got here tonight
i'm gonna play a little bit of [ __ ]
uh
let's see
i'm gonna play when i was playing the
periscope how about a little bit of uh
in through the outdoor
in the evening how's that [ __ ]
sounds good
this show is brought to you by ring go
to ring.com
church right now to get free expedited
fedex shipping it's ring.com church for
the brand new best video doorbell on the
market show is also brought to you by
onit.com use codeword church to get 10
off all the great optimization products
thank you again
see you wednesday
have a great tuesday
good night [ __ ] in through the
outdoor
like i said before
1979
a tremendous [ __ ] album
you